you're watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
of the morning papers
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with the royal
commentator
victoria murphy and the writer and role
photographer
ian lloyd lovely to have you both with
us so let's see then what is
on some of those front pages the sunday
telegraph
leading with the funeral of the duke of
edinburgh which has taken place
in windsor the sunday times has a
wraparound front page displaying
an image of the service in saint
george's chapel
the headline inside the paper
reads forced to mourn alone the queen
bids philip
goodbye the mirror also holds a similar
headline
with the loneliest goodbye
a headline of support from the sunday
express reading you're not alone mom
and pictures her majesty sitting alone
at prince philip's funeral
the star also carrying that image
bless her they say the daily mail looks
into the inside story of how the duchess
of cambridge
helped to mend the relationship between
prince william and prince harry
the observer meanwhile leading with a
warning to the prime minister suggesting
the conservatives will lose the trust of
red will voters if he fails to take
action on the green sill lobbying round
but
again pictures her majesty so let's get
the thoughts the choices then of
victoria murphy
and ian lloyd and victoria what an
emotional and poignant set of
front pages they are absolutely
incredibly fitting for the occasion
today and i don't think it's any
surprise at all that so many of the
front pages feature that
photograph of the queen sitting on her
own in the chapel choir with this huge
expanse of pews next to her
isolated and alone without her husband
of 17 more than 70 years by her side and
i think when we all saw that picture
earlier on today taken by a press
association photographer it was very
clear that that was a very iconic image
you know it really sums up
the situation that she is now in but
it's also a very iconic i think
photograph for our times you know we
have that picture because
this was a funeral that took place in
covid times and she is sitting alone
because of social distancing
and wearing a mask it's not a photograph
we could ever have seen at a royal
funeral
two years ago and hopefully not one we
will ever see again so
incredibly iconic i think a challenge
for the papers because obviously it's a
landscape picture and the newspapers are
in portrait and
i think you know actually the mirror has
done a very good job of sort of creating
that that expansive feel and the feeling
of her being isolated
yes let's take a look at the mirror then
um the loneliest goodbye
they say um but ian what are your
thoughts about the duke of edinburgh how
he would have felt about today
despite those images um you followed him
what for more than 500 royal engagements
many of his
carriage driving competitions as well as
several state visits
would he have liked it no fast paired
down absolutely i mean yes
i think he would have thought it was
terrific because i mean even before
covert his
his funeral was going to be much more
dif more different from
or the queen mothers it wasn't going to
be a lavish states ceremony there was
going to be no lying in state in london
no parade from
westminster to paddington then a train
to windsor and all of that
it was all going to be centered around
windsor i think anything we might have
had was a pageantry down the
um the long walk a bit of a sort of a a
walk down there if you like and um
for the public to see but apart from
that that would have been it really so
obviously he didn't wouldn't have
expected the uh covered restriction but
i think the very fact that you
didn't get ambassadors their politicians
uh lord mayors and everything would have
delighted him to be honest
i think sometimes he got rather crossed
i know he used to call when there was a
posse of mares turning up he used to say
oh here's the chain gang again
so i think he would have been quite
happy not to have um
not to have had all of those people
there
that's interesting isn't it and as we
look here at the family
obviously in morning suits victoria
would you have minded though the loss of
the uniforms do you think a decision
that uh
the queen took um in order presumably to
spare prince harry's blushes
yeah i mean much discussion about that
before the funeral um when it was
announced that that was going to happen
but actually today it really wasn't the
focus at all i
i certainly don't think he would have
minded i think he would have very much
understood
the decision and the reasons behind it i
think also what we sort of saw with this
funeral because it was so paired back it
actually became very much
a family funeral so the fact that they
weren't in
that military uniform i think didn't
didn't seem as
at odds we didn't have the scale of
military spectacle that we would have
had in normal times
i think uh another very powerful sort of
visual of the day
um obviously his coffin with his royal
standard flag you know
representing his position but also on
top of that
um his navel cap and sword and i think
the telegraph chose to
to put a picture showing that on their
front page
and i think really a really quite
powerful visual of
a reminder really of the military career
that he had
in the royal navy before um he before
the queen became queen and he stepped
back from that military position
um and it was a sacrifice that he made
because he understood that when he
married her he had a different kind of
duty to do and he completely had signed
up to that
and i think sort of seeing that that cap
on top of the coffin today i think
evoked images of him as a young naval
officer that we've seen so many pictures
of him in that role recently
um so very fitting i think that that was
shown
yes the sunday telegraph as you said
with a really dramatic
photograph there um the sword given by
um
the queen's father as well so all of
these all of these things
hop back to this really long association
he's had with the royal family
he's known the queen what ian for for 80
years
married for 73 of them that much of the
focus of the newspaper is not surprised
on her majesty the queen and as you have
followed um
those engagements that they've held
together how will she
do you think cope without him well i
think
obviously the queen's got cutie
ingrained in her i mean i think she's um
she's almost enjoyed her role over the
years
i think things like the uh her executive
role of
the red boxes that she goes through each
day i think she she copes very well with
those
and i once asked her cousin margaret
rhodes how
the queen copes with pressure and she
said well she's got the ability to
compartmentalize her life so she
you know if tomorrow she's going to open
parliament she doesn't think about it at
that moment
it could be something else to occupy her
mind and she will give that her full
attention and then think well tomorrow
i'll
concentrate on the other thing so she
has that ability and then of course
she's got other things like the family
the several members prince andrew and
prince edward are nearby in windsor then
there's a bubble people like angela
kelly and her
um her dresser angela kelly and her
paige or wybrook people like that live
alongside
and now two extra corgis which she um
she's
porgy puppies which she's going to be
occupied walking
um so i suppose there's going to be a
few you know
diversions yes exactly the new dogs as
the papers described in the in the last
few days uh the lady in waiting of
course who
accompanied her today uh baroness hussey
part of this
ensemble of people who are still around
have been part of hms bubble
victoria do you think you know this idea
you'll never walk alone
um already some of the grandchildren
have done engagements with her
how will the family be rallying around
do you think supporting
her majesty as she goes on i mean her
birthday only next week
will she feel their full support despite
the difficulties of kovid
i think absolutely and i think we've
really seen that you know we've seen
members of the royal family pay visits
to her sophie countess of wessex said
you know the queen's been amazing and i
think
we're absolutely going to see them
support her i mean they have been doing
so already
prince philip remember retired in 2017
so he has been missing from public life
for a few years although of course
it is sort of particularly poignant now
to see her photographed on her own
because
even though we've seen her on her own in
public life before now we sort of know
that when she goes home
she'll still be on her own and there is
something i think more poignant about
that
but i certainly think we will see the
family support her i mean we're not in
normal times at the moment
so engagements are not being carried out
so it's very hard to get a sense of how
things will look when things do
hopefully go back to normal and engage
engagements resume at the same level and
but i certainly think we will see her
attending events with
family members i think we will still see
her carry out audiences and
do duties on her own in the way that she
has been
yes and maybe more of those you know
virtual zoom type meetings which she's
become used to
um the times uh front page they wrap
around
shows the drama of the occasion really
doesn't it with some 700
military personnel taking taking part
but i'm just going to read alison
pearson's words in the telegraph
it was a heartbreakingly beautiful day
almost too glorious
for a funeral but the spring sunshine in
which when windsor castle with bathed
felt true to the remarkable warmth love
even which the nation felt
for the dearly departed and i return ian
to that thought that
for many people watching at home some of
whom may have had the privilege of
meeting
prince philip it was really a dramatic
but emotional day for them
certainly dramatic years and actually
the sunday times photographs do show the
drama because i think the last big
occasion we remember was the wedding of
prince harry and meghan markle
where megan was walking down with the uh
the aisle with all the people on either
side of her and then
this striking image of the funeral uh
procession with of course
nobody around it looking very stark
and same outside normally we used to you
know bridegroom attendance and so on
it's a very minimal minimalist sort of
shock
and it does remind us also prince
philip's great involvement with
george's chapel he was actually quite a
religious person
he had over 630 books on religion in his
library
and he was a practicing christian and he
attended church quite often
and as we said today i mean he was so
often
there over the last 70 years alongside
the queen
so it's very poignant for him not to be
sitting alongside her today
well stark minimalist no fuss just as he
would have wanted perhaps